perú superó las 200.000 muertes por kobe
y 19 200.000 tres decesos en concreto
según anunció el ministerio de salud del
país después de que en la jornada del
viernes se registrarán 25 nuevos
fallecidos el ministerio de salud
lamenta informar que el kobe 19 ha
producido el fallecimiento de 200.000
tres ciudadanos en el país expresamos
nuestras sentidas condolencias en este
momento de dolor durante toda la
pandemia el país andino ha sido uno de
los países con mayor tasa de mortalidad
por kobe las imágenes de hospitales
colapsados y gente buscando oxígeno de
manera desesperada han sido comunes en
perú para tratar de rebajar el contagio
en centros hospitalarios desde el 15 de
octubre los trabajadores de la salud
empezaron a recibir una tercera dosis de
refuerzo de la vacuna me siento más
protegido no gracias a la tercera 12
cuando están dando no a la primera línea
y tener un mejor contacto claro con los
pacientes más seguridad a consecuencia
de la pandemia el pib cayó un 11 12 por
ciento en 2020 lo que sumado a la rebaja
de la tasa de contagio llevó a relajar
las medidas sanitarias en el país el
toque de queda se redujo a dos horas y
los restaurantes operan al cien por cien
de aforo sin embargo ante la alta tasa
de mortalidad y contagios que aún
registra perú el viernes el ministerio
recomendó seguir manteniendo la
distancia social y usar la mascarilla